Hi, I'm
Amy Poehler,
and I'm standing in front
of a bunch of books,
which means
I'm smart
and you have something
to learn from me.
Let's get started.
In my class, we're
going to discuss
how these
improv principles
affect your
real life.
It's for people working,
in relationships, parents.
You know, how
do you deal with
kind of the everyday
humanness of life?
Who's next?
I need to break up
with my boyfriend.
Can't be
halfway in.
When you see someone
half commit to something,
hell is the
hallway, right?
You're just
kind of stuck
straddling between
two worlds.
It limits you
from connection,
experience, and being
in the present moment.
Don't bail on
your partners.
So many sketches
at SNL bombed,
but everybody held on
to that bucking bronco
until it rode
out of town.
It is so hard to
hang in, but man,
people do
not forget that.
I am a big proponent of doing
things before you're ready.
You can watch
the parade go by
and you can say,
“I'm just going to wait
for the perfect float.”
But if we are all waiting to be 100%
ready, the parade will go by.
I'm Amy Poehler,
and this is
American Idol
MasterClass.